you think America is a racist
country it's really hard to say no and
the reason why is because how racism has
been baked into so many of our
institutions I wouldn't say I think
there's a difference between saying I
feel like when people say is America a
racist country they're trying to add the
like the moral perjorative that it's
like well he thinks everyone is I'm
America racist I think the way in which
America has been founded and operated
like yeah I think so today it's a racist
country oh yeah how many vestiges how
many black people have immigrated to the
US over the last 20 years about 3
million 2 million from Africa and a
million from the why would they come to
America if America was so racist great
question